The Sopranos was the first jewel in
HBO's prestige TV crown known for its
unpredictable plot gritty realism and
introducing the word gabagool to people
outside of New Jersey but perhaps the
biggest key to the show's success was
the talented ensemble cast most of whom
he learns to love and hate an equal
measure over the course of six
unforgettable seasons he is where your
favorite Sopranos actors are now Edie
Falco as Carmela soprano critical
acclaim followed Edie Falco into a first
major post Sopranos project showtimes
Nurse Jackie with the Brooklyn born
actress playing the namesake role in the
edgy drama D from 2009 until it came to
an end in 2015 she later moved on to
Louis CK's popular 2016 webseries
horison Pete and has dabbled in movies
in recent years though she hasn't left
TV behind her recent projects include
the Law & Order miniseries true crime
the Menendez murders
Robert oiler as AJ soprano after the
Sopranos
Robert Isla gave up acting for poker
moving to Las Vegas in 2012 so he could
focus on the World Series of Poker
full-time after entering the high stakes
competition on a handful of occasions as
a youngster he says his obsession with
card games has started when his
grandmother taught him out to play rummy
and Gen jamie-lynn Sigler as Meadow
Soprano like Robert Isla jamie-lynn
Sigler peaked early with The Sopranos
never managing to outgrow it despite her
best efforts she tried to launch a
career in pop music during the show's
run though when that died in her timers
meadow ended opportunities were hard to
come by
the real reason for a sparse filmography
was revealed in 2016 when the actress
admitted that she had been suffering
from MS for almost 15 years saying the
last time she had the energy to run was
while filming The Sopranos finale
Michael Imperioli as Christopher
Moltisanti in the years since his
character was killed off by Tony Michael
Imperioli hasn't managed to find the
same levels of acclaim he enjoyed while
playing the tragic Christopher as a
quick glance at his splats heavy watson
Tomatoes record proofs off his last 15
films reviewed by the websites network
of critics 13 have been declared rotten
in the spring of 2017 he was
lord back to television appearing
Cossack brass right-hand man in the ABC
comedy Alex incorporated Dre DiMatteo as
adriana la cerva whale Queens born
actress Dre de Matteo has dabbled in
film from time to time she stuck with TV
for the most part since meeting her end
in The Sopranos
she played joey tribbiani's sister Gina
in his short-lived friend spin-off
brassy italian-american Angie in
Desperate Housewives and the Jax's ex
wife Wendy in Sons of Anarchy before
supporting Jennifer Lopez and the NBC
cop drama shades of blue steven van
zandt a Silvio Dante a guitarist and
Bruce Springsteen's E Street Band Steven
Van Zant had never acted in a major role
before portraying Silvio Dante on The
Sopranos after his character was left
comatose in the finale he went back to
music of course but also had a stint on
Lillehammer the first ever Netflix
original series Netflix pulled the plug
in 2015
handling the show after three seasons
and Van Zandt hasn't appeared on-screen
in anything since Tony Sirico as Paulie
walnuts real-life ex-con and
self-described former pistol packin guy
Tony Sirico reunited with Steven Van
Sant in Lillehammer for two episodes
starting in 2013 and with Woody Allen
for 2016's cafe society having appeared
in the past and Allan's bullets over
Broadway and a deconstructing Harry
Sirico hasn't done much in the year
since though he occasionally cashes in
on his tough-guy image with cameos
Dominic kanae's a as uncle jr. best
known for his role as Tony's
pain-in-the-ass uncle junior
Dominic kanae's a plied his trade post
Sopranos on 12 episodes of Boardwalk
Empire
another gangland hit for HBO outside of
acting
kanae Z has a side career as a tenor
which won't Khmers are surprised two
Sopranos fans who watched him bring
grown mobsters to tears with his
performance in the season 3 finale he
hasn't given up on acting recent
projects include a remake of the
post-war Italian masterpiece Umberto D
James Gandolfini as Tony Soprano the
late James Gandolfini made his living as
a character actor before being cast in
the career-defining role of Tony Soprano
following Gandolfini's 2013 death from a
heart attack while on vacation in Rome
with his family
Sopranos
runner David Chase paid tribute to his
leading man calling him a genius
Gandolfini was on a real run when he
passed appearing in five Rotten Tomatoes
certified fresh films in the space of
two years felt corny when you broke my
heart
and I'm too old for that thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your loved team